[Music]
what is the slope of a vertical line
intuitively the question doesn't make
any sense right we know that the slope
of a straight line measures its
steepness so how steep is a vertical
line we encounter situations like this
in these types of functions observe the
graph of the functions near X equal to
zero if we want to draw a tangent line
here we would immediately draw a
vertical line like this but previously
we've seen that the slope of a tangent
line tells us the rate of change of a
function that is its derivative so
what's the derivative at X equal to zero
here
or indirectly what's the slope of a
vertical line we can now understand
these cases in this video let's start
with this function in the previous video
we saw how we can intuitively understand
whether the derivative exists or not at
a point just by looking at a functions
graph if after zooming around that point
the graph doesn't look almost like a
straight line that we know that the
derivative does not exist at that point
so what does this tell us about this
function at X equal to zero if we zoom
in here we can see that it looks like a
vertical line so does this mean the
derivative exists at this point let's
see by now we are familiar with how to
find the derivative of a function in
order to find this limit of the average
rate as Delta X tends to zero we
consider two cases first when Delta X is
greater than zero and second when Delta
X is less than zero so can you find the
average rate of change in these two
cases let's look at the calculations
quickly in the first case let Delta X be
equal to H and in the second case
negative of H in both the cases H is a
positive number now if we calculate the
average rate in the first case we will
get that to be equal to one over H
raised to the power 1 over 3 we proceed
in a similar way for this second case
here it will be equal to negative of 1
over H raised to the power 1 over 3 now
can you tell me what's the next step we
know we need to find whether these
average rates approach the same number
as Delta X that is H tends to 0 for this
let's represent these average rates on a
number line in the first case the
average rate will be a positive number
and in the second case it will be a
negative number
now as H tends to 0 in the first case
the value of average rate will move up
on the number line that is it will
approach a larger positive number and in
the second case its value will move down
on the number line that is it will
approach a smaller negative number so we
see that as Delta X tends to 0 in both
the cases the average rate does not
approach any particular number in the
first case we say that as Delta X tends
to 0 plus the average rate tends to
positive infinity and in the second case
as Delta X tends to 0 minus the average
rate tends to negative infinity it means
that in both the cases the magnitude of
average rate keeps on increasing so from
this we can conclude that this limit of
the average rate does not exist as Delta
X tends to 0 so this means that the
derivative of this function at X equal
to 0 does not exist even though the very
small region of graph near X equal to 0
looks like a
straightline the derivative doesn't
exist at this point so what does all
this mean geometrically let's continue
this in the next part
let's divide the graph of the function
into two parts corresponding to these
two cases these average rates will be
equal to the slope of the corresponding
secant lines on the graph for the first
case the slope of the secant line will
be positive and equal to one over H
raised to the power 1 over 3 in the
second case it will be equal to the
negative of 1 over H raised to the power
1 over 3 now we can see that as Delta X
tends to 0 these secant lines will
approach these vertical straight lines
but now the derivative of this function
does not exist because we cannot define
the slope of a vertical line why for
example consider the straight line graph
of a function let's say the slope of the
straight line is M so it means for any
two points on this line the ratio of
change in Y over change in X is equal to
M so the slope tells us how fast or slow
the value of y changes with respect to X
but now observe these vertical lines for
any two points on it the change in X
will always be zero so we cannot define
this ratio here
hence the slope of a vertical straight
line is undefined
now one subtle thing to observe is that
these two vertical lines are not the
same according to this we can say that
in the first case the secant line
approaches a tangent line with infinite
slope but the slope is always positive
while in the second case we can say that
the secant line approaches a tangent
line with infinite slope but the slope
is always negative so in the first case
the tangent is directed in this
direction and in the second case in this
direction so we see that we get two
different tangent lines at the same
point
therefore to start with in this case a
tangent line at X equal to zero
does not exist and so the derivative
doesn't exist in a graph of a function
this type of pattern is called a cusp
here X equal to zero does not hold any
special significance a cusp can occur at
any point in the graph of the function
it's formed at the point on the graph
when the average rate of change in these
two cases approaches infinite slope of
opposite signs so if we find a cusp at
any point on a functions graph we can
directly say that the derivative of the
function does not exist at that point
until now we have seen two different
types of sharp turns when the function
changes abruptly one is a corner point
like this and the other is a cusp we
thought that the derivative of these
types of points does not exist in the
case of a corner we get two different
tangents with a finite slope and in the
case of a cusp we get two different
tangents with infinite slopes in short
the derivative of these points doesn't
exist because we cannot find a straight
line by which we can approximate the
graph of the function around that point
now there might occur sharp turns which
are combinations of these two types as
Delta X tends to 0 from the side we get
a tangent line with a finite slope and
from the other side we get a tangent
line with infinite slope in such cases
also we can now directly see that the
derivative at such points does not exist
now what about this function we
mentioned in the beginning what will be
the derivative at X equal to 0
intuitively we can see that the
derivative will not exist at X equal to
0 this is because we will get that the
tangent line at X equal to 0 will be a
vertical straight line how
if we find the average rate in two cases
as earlier we will get this here we see
that the average rate in both the cases
is the same the secant lines
corresponding to these averages will
look like this now we can see that as
Delta X tends to zero
these secant lines will approach this
same vertical straight line so we get
this vertical tangent line at X equal to
zero but as we saw earlier the slope of
this vertical tangent line is undefined
we say that it's infinite so the
derivative does not exist here
such vertical tangent lines can occur at
any point on the graph of a function so
in such cases we can directly say that
the derivative does not exist at that
point so we saw different types of
situations where the derivative of a
function does not exist at these points
the function changes suddenly or rapidly
so to find the rate of change we cannot
approximate the graph around such points
by a straight line now let me ask you a
question
so far we've learnt that for a function
we can find its derivative at a
particular value of x it is equal to the
slope of the tangent line at that point
on the functions graph now the important
question is isn't the derivative of a
function also a function what do you
think share your thoughts in the comment
section below and subscribe to our
channel to keep learning
[Music]